there's a lot of misinformation about
the upcoming
election we want to clear that up for
our viewers
and i have clark county registrar joe
gloria here to help clear this
up we are in front of the room where the
ballots will be
counted and that's one question how can
voters be sure
that their ballot was received and will
be counted
all voters will have the opportunity to
go on our website
through registered voter services they
can
log in and there's information there
that tells them what the status of their
ballot is
or they can always call 702 455 vote
and speak with one of our customer
service representatives who can answer
those questions for them
there is this push to vote in person
in the middle of the pandemic what would
you say to that
we've made it available in the primary
we had limited resources and
availability
that won't be the case for the general
we have a full early voting schedule 35
sites scheduled over 14 days
and also on election day there will be
125 vote centers
available and also important to note all
early voting and all election day vote
centers
will also serve as mail ballot drop-off
locations
there is a concern about voter fraud if
there are
extra ballots by mailboxes especially
apartment complexes
or someone picks up a ballot that's not
theirs that they can fill it out
sign it what can you say about voter
fraud
well first off that would be an illegal
action it would be against the law for
anybody to vote a ballot that is not
theirs
however we have several checks in place
number one being every ballot that comes
in has to be signed
we verify that signature to make sure it
matches what's in the database
to verify their identity and there are
several steps that we have as far as
security also
leading into the tabulation of that
ballot president donald trump
has suggested voting twice what would
you say to that
that would be an illegal action
and it's unfortunate that those types of
statements are made i would discourage
any voter from trying to do so we will
definitely know
if you've casted two ballots and we will
go after
any voter who is illegally voting twice
southern nevada las vegas it's a
transient
location and especially now with the
pandemic and job losses
people might be in between homes
how can you be sure that they will
receive a ballot
voters need to make sure that they're
checking to be sure that their
information is correct
so now is the time to update your
information if you've moved
because mail ballots are not forwardable
whatever address we send it to if
there's nobody there
it gets returned to us so voters please
go
online if you have a nevada driver's
license or id and update your
information
or before the october 6 deadline get a
form filled out with the updated
information and get it to our office so
we can get your ballot to you
the usps sent a postcard then the
secretary of state
sent another postcard they both said two
different things can you clear this up
we want to make sure that voters are
aware in clark county and really the
state of nevada
you do not need to apply for a mail-in
ballot
all active registered voters will be
sent according to statute av4 a mail
ballot
so you do not need to submit a request
so it was a little confusing in the usps
mailer
but we want to make that clear you will
receive your ballot if you're actively
registered
the primary you mentioned there were
limited resources there were long
lines what is your prediction for
election night and can you talk about
the locations and again the difference
well we'll still have the same safety
procedures in place
we're trying to provide a safe
environment there's plenty of
disinfecting equipment master being
provided
face shields are being provided there's
a separator a plexiglas shield where
people sign in to vote and we're
creating
what we call a voting cubicle in all of
our stations to keep people safe while
they vote
we'll encourage people to social
distance and we'll encourage them to
wear a mask and we'll have masks
available for those who forget to bring
one
and can you run down some numbers how
many locations how many voting machines
how many workers and volunteers the
number of machines varies by side
according to how much room we have but
for the early voting process
over 14 days we'll have 35 teams
scheduled to go out
and set up on a daily basis also for
election day there will be 125
vote centers available for voters and
again i emphasize
both early voting and election day sites
will also serve as male ballot drop-off
locations
for anybody who wants to drop off their
ballot instead of putting it in the post
office
do you need additional election workers
and is it a challenge
finding them because of the pandemic and
many of them are seniors
we were short workers in the month of
august but once i put the call out
we got help from the county commission
we got help from several third party
groups that work with us regularly and
we're looking good to supply workers for
125 sites on election day and the early
voting program
however we're still looking for people
who have the ability to translate
in spanish and filipino so if you're
able to work and interested please
contact our office
misinformation have you ever seen it
like this
leading up to an election every election
is a challenge this is my
presidential election so i've seen quite
a bit of misinformation
that goes out it's our job to make sure
we get the good information out in doing
interviews like this that's what exactly
what we try to do
voters keep an eye on the mail you'll be
getting a sample ballot filled with
accurate information
a mail ballot supplement and your mail
ballot impacted we're also doing a
virtual town hall tomorrow night
that people can log into and watch
please watch that we'll be providing
a lot of good information in that town
hall if i'm a voter in nevada what are
three things i need to know voters in
nevada need to know
that you need to update your information
we want to send a mail ballot to the
correct address to make sure that you
get it
voters in nevada also need to know that
we have in-person voting
ability for early voting and election
day
and finally i would express to all
voters the integrity of the process in
elections is something that we take very
seriously
not just in clark county but at the
state level with the secretary of
state's office
we will do everything on our power to
make sure that we process ballots
correctly
and everything is done to uphold the
integrity of the process
do you think clark county
will have results on election night
there will be no final results on
election night
we will definitely be reporting an
unofficial total
for our in-person early voting and
election day sites minus the provisional
votes
but the mail ballots will be counted for
several days after election day so our
final unofficial won't be available to
well
after election day for anyone who
who may not know what is your role and
how is it different
from the secretary of state well the
secretary of state
oversees the entire state i'm only
responsible for clark county
although the majority of voters in the
state of nevada reside in clark county
so i'm responsible for the local
activities with all elections
the secretary of state monitors the
entire state
estimate total voters in clark county
1.2 million at this point
how has the pandemic increased the cost
of this election as opposed to previous
elections
oh there has been a significant increase
in cost um
we're providing mail ballots to every
active voter that's not something we
normally do
in a big election comparing it to the
2018 2016
we would send out maybe 70 or 80 000
mail ballots
compared to the 1.2 million that we'll
be sending out
the processing of those mail ballots
also we had to incur several
costs and the pandemic has caused us to
make sure
that we have plenty of safety equipment
disinfectant mass
all that's necessary to keep our workers
and our voters safe as they're casting
their ballot
any concerns about election security
and in particular cyber security
cyber security is an issue that's never
going away it's a constant battle
we've taken extreme steps here in clark
county
and complements to our central i.t
department that stays on top of that for
us
we've done everything we can here
locally to make sure that all of our
information is safe
important to keep in mind our tabulation
system is completely isolated there's no
connection to the internet and every one
of our in-person
uh voting systems is also isolated so
there's no access to the internet
so we've done considerable work there
and we feel comfortable that we've done
everything we can
so there have been no hacks or anything
this year
not that i'm aware of do you know how
many attempts there might have been
no no anything you want to add
we want voters to cast their ballot
we've done a lot of work to make sure
that we're prepared
to support in a very challenging time
with a pandemic
voters keep in mind that if you're
concerned at all make use of the mail
and ballot keeping in mind also
this is the longest ballot we've ever
seen in clark county vote it in the
comfort of your home do your research
mark your ballot and send it back make
sure you've signed the return
envelope not the ballot the return
envelope
send it to us or drop it off and we'll
make sure that that ballot gets
processed and counted
thank you so much less than 50 days from
the election
if you have questions let us know we
will try to get them answered for you
in north las vegas vanessa murphy 8 news
now